now the family of a British man who was
volunteering in Ukraine have confirmed
that he and his colleague have been
killed we'll get more on the snow from
Skies Emma birchley and uh Emma one of
the family said
yeah this confirmation coming from the
family of 28 year old Chris Parry that
both he and his colleague Andrew Bagshaw
a 48 year old had been killed while
volunteering in Ukraine they'd been
there working in the Donetsk region
um we're helping with humanitarian
efforts and with civilian evacuation and
they were on their way from crematorsk
heading for solidar at 8am on Friday the
January the 6th when they were last seen
a contact was lost and then the
following afternoon they were reported
missing so this evening we have received
a statement via the foreign office from
Chris Paris family it says it is with
great sadness we have to announce that
our beloved Chrissy has been killed
along with his colleague Andrew Bagshaw
whilst attempting a humanitarian
evacuation from solidar Eastern Ukraine
his selfless determination in helping
the old young and disadvantaged there
has made us and his larger family
extremely proud he found himself drawn
to Ukraine in March in its darkest hour
at the start of the Russian invasion and
helped those most in need saving over
400 lives plus many abandoned animals
it's impossible to put into words how
much he will be missed but he will be
forever in our hearts and I think that's
something that Chris himself had told
Sky News on a number of occasions that
need to go and work there he was drawn
to help so something the families have
been dreading but now that confirmation
that both Chris parry and Andrew Bagshaw
have been killed in Ukraine okay Emma
thank you very much indeed for that and
uh while I'm has been talking uh we've
had a statement from the family of
Andrew Bagshaw who's Emma was saying was
killed alongside Chris parry and this
says it has been confirmed that our son
Dr Andrew Bagshaw has died he and a
colleague Chris Parry were attempting to
rescue an elderly woman from solidar in
an area of intense military action when
their car was hit by an artillery shell
the Ukrainian authorities and government
officials in New Zealand and London have
been working hard to learn more details
but little further is known about the
circumstances of his death due to
official legal processes in Ukraine
it'll be sometime before Andrew's
remains are returned to New Zealand
Andrew selflessly took many personal
risks and saved many lives we love him
and a very proud indeed of what he did
that from the family of Dr Andrew
backshaw killed alongside Chris paria
according to the backshaw family when an
artillery shell hit their car near
solidar in the east of Ukraine when they
were trying to evacuate an elderly woman